Fred Barker and his mother, Ma Parker, died in
their Florida bungalow their bodies riddled with
machine-gun bullets. The year 1935 found the G-Men
working at top speed many kidnappers were rounded
up. Among whom was Bruno Richard Hauptmann who
died in the electric chair for the kidnapping
of the Lindbergh baby. Alvin Karpis who more than
two years ago shot his way out of an Atlantic City
hotel was captured in an apartment in New Orleans
on May 1st, 1936 by J Edgar Hoover and his G-Men.
Quickly following his capture Harry Campbell
one of Karpis' henchmen was captured in Toledo,
Ohio. Before the papers could get onto the street
with this announcement, G-Men reported the capture
of William Mahan wanted in the Weyerhaeuser
kidnapping. Climaxing a sensational ten-day
roundup of the nation's public enemies on May
11th, 1936 the federal agents captured the last
of the public enemies Thomas H. Robinson for the
kidnapping of Mrs. Alice Stoll. The alertness
of this obscure clerk, Lynn Allen, led to
Robinson's capture - who walked in as a woman to
the drugstore where Allen was employed and whose
suspicions were so aroused by Robinson's actions
that he notified the Pasadena Authority. The G-Men
were called in and he was soon traced to this
modest little home in Glendale, California where
he was taken without a struggle. The gangsters are
vanishing from our nation. Crime can and will be
put down in America. The Department of Justice is
leading the way and deserves of both of thanks
from every right-thinking person in America.